la régularité c'est la meilleure amie du
sommeil régularité c'est la meilleure
amie du soleil c'est la meilleure amie
de la vie être régulier dans la vie
c'est ce qui vous mènera à une vie saine
et une vie longue regardez Daniel elle
est régulière dans la médiocrité
elle m'a dit jusqu'à 450 ans et les mecs
je parle comme je veux c'est ma meuf
encore on est ensemble on se dit les
choses elle me dit ce qu'elle dit
qu'elle pense de moi voilà chérie
calme-toi quand même
alors on va vous donner avec Brigitte
Lady conseil pour bien dormir alors déjà
conseil numéro 1 c'est se lever à la
même heure tous les matins même le
weekend c'est-à-dire pourquoi pas
évident non plus d'y arriver mais c'est
vraiment ce qui permettra de mieux
dormir parce que en fait le problème
c'est que on a on peut agir sur le leur
du réveil mais on peut pas agir sur
l'oeil lors de l'endormissement on peut
pas dire allez dors donc forcément on va
agir sur le réveil et comme ça petit à
petit parce qu'on va réguler son sommeil
et on va pouvoir s'endormir sur lors du
sommeil on peut agir parce que moi pas
que moi par exemple moi j'ai un
médicament vous pouvez vous dire j'ai
payé un hypnotiseur qui est là tout le
temps
voilà il arrive chez moi il fait dehors
voilà merci on est le matin désactive
alors sinon il faut il faut pas alterner
les couchers tardives dans la semaine
procrastiner et les grosses matinées
exactement et sinon parce que moi c'est
ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé un
moment c'est que j'ai perturbé mon
rythme circadien
je sais que ça vous parle pas à vous
mais
non mais c'est vrai qu'il régule ça
régule le sommeil
donc il faut vraiment respecter ce
rythme s'il y a l'éveil et s'il y a la
nu si elle le jour et la nuit c'est
justement pour qu'on puisse dormir la
nuit parce qu'en fait dès que
l'obscurité arrive il y a une hormone
qui s'appelle la mélatonine qui est
sécrétée et qui est l'hormone de
l'endormissement et donc là vous pouvez
dormir et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
respecter une chambre bien noire du noix
et surtout qu'il ne faut pas regarder
normalement les écrans puisqu'il y a une
lumière bleue donc la sécrétion de la
mélatonine
mec j'ai des écrans partout ah bon
[Rires]
oui oui
je me suis fait un petit plaisir bleu
dans la télé que dans les écrans et moi
je regarde que des émissions en plus
je regarde enquête criminel je regarde
tout comme ça le problème c'est que il
faut savoir écouter son corps et quand
on dit pas de procrastination c'est
parce qu'il faut pas remettre de dès que
vous sentez que ça commence à arriver le
sommeil
non mais toi tu en as laissé passer des
trucs non mais c'est toute une carte
alors deuxième conseil pour bien dormir
limiter au maximum les siestes
on peut faire des siècles pour ta
rentrée dans un cycle de sommeil c'est à
dire 15 minutes 20 minutes c'est bon
mais si vous rentrez déjà parce que il y
a plusieurs sigles dans le sommeil si
vous rentrez déjà dans un cycle en fait
vous allez vous réveiller hyper mal quoi
alors que juste respecter la phase de
l'endormissement 15 minutes 20 minutes
là on se réveille en pleine forme et en
revanche si on n'a pas dormi de la nuit
si on affirmé que trois quatre heures
pour des raisons là on peut faire une
sieste d'une heure une heure et demie
puisqu'on reprend tous les cycles du
sommeil
parce que c'est vrai que moi je fais je
fais en fait moi je fais deux nuits en
fait trois quatre heures la nuit et
trois quatre heures la prochaine pour
moi ça respectait si vous respectez rien
vous vous respectez rien composé son
dîner manger un repas trop copieux épicé
ou trop riche en protéines le soir
risque d'alterner le sommeil et
d'altérer surtout le sommeil pendant la
digestion étant apprécius un processus
en fait voilà tu vas trop digérer moi
c'est à moi je pensais que le soir je
ne mange que des boulettes
en plus
équilibré mais surtout il y a des faux
amis déjà il faut pas d'accident pour
éviter tout ce qui est café
tout ce qui peut être excitant et
ensuite il faut je vais le regarde plus
il faut faire attention la fausse amie
c'est l'alcool parce qu'effectivement on
va mieux s'endormir mais en revanche
après on va mal dormir alors pour moi
l'alcool c'est pas faux amis c'est un
vrai
santé non mais c'est est-ce qu'il y en a
qui sont dorment en prenant un petit
verre
juste avant de dormir
alors là Brigitte là là vous me fassiez
partout parce que le quatrième conseil
écoutez bien si vous êtes chez vous il
est 19h50 on est en direct vous dites
pour bien dormir pas d'écran dans la
chambre la chambre est exclusivement
réservée au sommet il y a l'intimité
alors moi Brigitte ça ça pour moi il y a
pas une plus grosse angoisse que ça
c'est genre take ta meuf allez on va se
coucher maintenant
et là tu vas
aller on éteint
Patricia on est temps allez c'est parti
mais c'est insupportable non mais
franchement je suis obligé moi je suis
obligé de regarder la télé mais vous en
profitez pour faire d'autres choses
quand vous avez pas d'écran
tu veux venir je te rappelle que je suis
le chef j'ai pas d'ici on va manger
voilà exceptionnellement regarde avec ça
non non mais c'est vrai Brigitte oui
mais la lumière bleue on vient de le
dire ça me tient en éveil non seulement
la lumière bleue mais aussi souvent
l'émotion que vous ressentez ou parfois
ce sont des jeux un petit peu excitant
un petit peu énervant etc les enquêtes
tu continues ton cerveau continue à
faire les enquêtes donc c'est ça qui est
chiant quoi tu es en train de poursuivre
Dark Vador toute la nuit
arrive le matin tu es crever quoi vous
comprenez c'est vrai
elle me comprend très bien
on a un bon contact
non mais Brigitte donc non mais c'est
les écrans comment on fait pour moi
alors il y a plein de gens qui nous
regardent je suis sûr et certain parce
qu'après ce qui se passe c'est que tu
fais comme Jean-Michel maire tu t'endors
dans le salon et là tu es éclaté tu te
réveilles dans la nuit tu t'es endormi
en plus moi j'ai pas de télécommande
parce que j'ai pas pu voilà j'ai une
télé ou je vais appuyer comme ça
le truc comme ça
[Applaudissements]
merci Gégé merci non non
de moins en moins c'est évidemment la
faute aux écrans mais il faut pas
oublier une chose je le sommeil c'est
quand même si on passe un tiers de notre
vie à dormir c'est parce que c'est
indispensable moi si j'avais un super
pouvoir ce serait de ne jamais on est en
train de faire une génération d'obèses
avec ce problème de sommeil parce que le
poids se régule la nuit la première
question qu'un médecin pose à quelqu'un
qui a un problème de poids c'est est-ce
que vous dormez bien parce que c'est
pendant le sommeil qu'on régule
et d'ailleurs pendant le sommeil tout
est bien fait l'hormone de l'appétit
elle diminue l'hormone de la satiété
l'augmente pour pas que vous ayez ça et
que vous ayez envie de vous couper
prochain la nuit quand on se lève dans
la nuit moi j'ai une petite fringale
peut-être d'autres choses mais
[Rires]
je vous assure qu'on est en train de
faire une génération il y a de l'obésité
est en train d'augmenter en France mais
là avec les jeunes qui ont des problèmes
de sommeil on va avoir des problèmes de
poids de plus en plus important et ça
c'est important de le dire il faut
expliquer aux enfants à quel point le
sommeil est important c'est là qui
grandisse c'est la tout se met en place
dans le cerveau tout ça
la nuit faut laisser la porte de chambre
ouverte pour que les kilos ils puissent
se barrer c'est ça
qui dort dîner
c'est dans les auberges à l'époque qui
veut dormir dans une chambre doit dîner
on doit payer son repas sinon tu dors
dans la grange
je veux dire que c'est vrai que ça fait
chez Daniel c'était qui dorken
[Applaudissements]
Brigitte tu es un cinquième Conseil se
détendre avant d'aller au lit et vous
dites et plus si affinité qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire et on calmez-vous
on fait quoi il faut il faut se détendre
on dort mieux quand on a la conscience
tranquille donc si vous allez en
ruminant tous vos problèmes de la
journée etc etc vous aurez du mal à vous
endormir ils ont pas des problèmes de
fou
on parle pour éviter les spectateurs
mais c'est important de mettre toutes
les conditions et d'être heureux d'aller
se coucher les gens on a l'impression
que les gens se disent que ça sert à
rien de sommeil que c'est une perte de
temps il y a 20% des gens qui pensent
que c'est une perte de temps c'est pas
du tout une perte de temps le sommeil et
je crois qu'il faudrait arriver à
éduquer les enfants maintenant à leur
expliquer voilà ce qui va se passer
pendant le sommeil tu vas grandir tu vas
cicatriser il va y avoir plein de choses
et si vous lui raconter une belle
histoire est-ce qu'on content d'aller
dormir peu
plus de 8h par jour et sinon la moyenne
on va dire c'est entre 7 et 8 heures
pour un adulte pour un ado un petit peu
plus il aurait besoin de plus le
problème c'est docteur vous décrivez un
monde idéal là moi quand je vais au lit
tout une trotte dans la tête surtout
quand il va au lit
vous avez tout à fait raison pareil pour
les écrans pareil pour tout c'est à mon
idéal mais on est là pour donner des
conseils de ce qui pourrait améliorer le
sommeil après faut pas oublier que le
sommeil c'est vraiment très dépendant
chacun a son rythme de sommeil mais vous
vous apercevez du problème de sommeil de
la journée quand on est crevé la journée
c'est pas normal on doit pas être crevé
la journée c'est qu'on a un problème de
sommeil et un bon sommeil ça se prépare
aussi une bonne nuit ça se prépare la
journée aussi faut avoir des activités
dans la journée quand on voit que tous
les gamins maintenant ils sont sur les
écrans en permanence ils peuvent par
exemple quand on a pas bougé de la
journée on a moins tendance à manger
est-ce qu'il y a des trucs comme
Béatrice
en fait les smartphones c'est pire que
la télévision parce qu'on perd la notion
du temps on commence à lire des choses à
et on perd le fil et on et puis on se
retrouve et les deux heures du matin et
on est toujours pas en train de dormir
donc c'est pour les jeunes c'est merci à
tous J'ai juste vous demander là pour la
par la suite je vais vraiment faire un
tout droit avec Brigitte merci
à tous non monsieur vous êtes très sympa
donc en sixième conseil pas de bain
chaud douche chaude oui parce qu'on dort
mieux à une température quand la
température corporelle donc faut éviter
d'aller dans le frigo
normal mais pas un bain chaud
contrairement à ce qu'on pouvait penser
que ça allait nous détendre
et pareil rien qui élève trop la
température corporelle donc pas une
activité physique après avant d'aller se
coucher
si on a une jeune femme comme Daniel qui
est dans la force de l'âge
dans cette activité physique à laquelle
vous semblez faire allusion là il y a
d'autres substances d'accord je des
endorphines etc qui vont vous apaiser et
qui vont vous aider à vous endormir
d'accord donc pour le 8 mars on a prévu
ensemble avec Daniel pas de souci avec
ça donc c'est douche froide hein et puis
après on verra ce qu'on fera exactement
en septième conseil ne pas surchauffer
la chambre malgré moi il fait très chaud
maintenant quand même assis dans même
dans ma chambre est chaude
c'est 20 degrés quoi
mais on dort mieux vous verrez essayez
de baisser on s'endort beaucoup mieux
quand la température de la chambre est à
18 19 degrés
[Rires]
entre 16 et 18 degrés c'est bien entre
16 et 18 degrés je le redis parce que
moi je dors vraiment
tout nu et j'ai peur de voilà que ce
soit trop frais et que le matin je me
réveille
j'ai peur de me réveiller qu'un Mister
Freeze
dont vous parlez il y en a plusieurs
dans la nuit il y en a entre chaque
on se réveille entre ainsi que c'est
1h30 il y a 4 à 5 cycles par nuit on se
réveille entre chaque cycle donc les
gens quand ils vous disent on s'est
réveillé je me suis réveillé j'ai pas
bien dormi non c'est tout à fait normal
de se réveiller plusieurs fois dans la
nuit parfois on s'en souvient parfois on
s'en souvient pas et ce dont vous parlez
on l'a aussi à chaque réveil t'inquiète
pas Daniel tu t'en souviendras
alors vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il
faut dormir dans l'obscurité la plus
totale alors j'ai vu qu'il y a des gens
ils mettaient des masques parfois là
comme ça c'est bien ça bah oui c'est il
y a pas de store s'il y a pas de moi
imaginons qu'il y a quelqu'un qui va
t'attaquer dans la nuit pour que tu
enlèves le masque non mais c'est vrai
puis le mec oh Batman je
comprends mieux pourquoi vous avez du
mal à vous endormir
moi je pourrai pas mettre le truc comme
ça il y en a de plus en plus de gens qui
mettent le masque comme ça des masques
et les boules qui est ça pour venir
quand ta meuf elle commence à mettre le
masque je peux te dire tu sais que il y
a une rupture dans les moins de 15 jours
c'est vraiment qu'elle veut vraiment
plus entendre ne plus voir ta gueule non
mais ça c'est sûr ta meuf elle arrive
même le masque même le masque tu sens
qu'il te regarde mal non mais c'est sûr
c'est vrai éviter les somnifères et les
psychos stimulants de café était oui les
somnifères c'est un leurre hein
déjà normalement la prescription ce qui
est officiel c'est pas plus de 4
semaines de somnifère d'affilée on sait
très bien que les gens les prennent
beaucoup plus mais surtout c'est un
leurre parce que en fait ça favorise pas
le sommeil c'est ça anesthésie le
cerveau et donc c'est pas du tout du
sommeil récupère vous vous êtes contents
mais vous n'avez pas récupérer toutes
les fonctions du sommeil elles n'ont pas
eu lieu j'ai pas entendu ce que vous
avez dit
prenez des somnifères ah non mais et je
vais vous dire moi et en plus c'est
tellement dans la tête moi je me
rappelle quand j'étais petit
et ben en fait moi je voilà je
n'arrivais pas à dormir parce que
j'étais petit genre voilà
planches du lit tout ça et ma mère pour
que je m'endorme elle me disait elle
m'avait donné elle faisait genre qu'elle
me donner du périaactine et un sirop
mais en fait elle mettait de l'eau
dedans avec du sucre en fait c'est en
fait je m'endormais quand même je
cassais plus rien c'est bien
donc c'est dans la tête c'est comme tu
vois c'est comme le 8 mars ça va être
dans la tête
il faut pas se lever du lit en cas de
longue insomnie il faut rester dans le
lit et dire on attend non au bout d'un
certain moment on peut pas rester dans
le livre ce qu'on peut faire c'est aller
faire une activité mais apaisante allez
lire écouter de la musique pas aller se
mettre à faire
elle vient de le dire tu étais là
[Rires]
le seul problème mais ce que vous
racontez c'est que moi la nuit je trouve
il y a plus de fâcheux le téléphone
sonne plus ça sonne plus à la porte on
est dans un monde un peu idéal on est
plus jamais emmerdé donc
idyllique la nuit alors que la journée
c'est là que les emmerde donc c'est dur
de dormir il va pas t'appeler la nuit
est-ce qu'il y a pas un côté qui est
meilleur que l'autre beaucoup de
médecins m'ont répondu sur ça pareil que
faut dormir du côté gauche c'est
beaucoup plus pour les organes internes
je parle ça vous parle ça vous parle
mais vous avez fait des des études quand
même au départ
il vaut mieux sortir
merci d'avoir été là